people le magazine Gala s'interroge
Lorie et Garou pourquoi ça dure entre
eux est-ce que quelqu'un a une idée
chacun maintenant Stéphane Guillon
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
Stéphane Guillon pour la semaine de
Stéphane Guillon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et on commence par un coup de chapeau
zebdomadaire français pour la diversité
de leur couverture et l'originalité des
sujets on peut les applaudir
[Applaudissements]
Isabelle Balkany souhaite 1000 ans de
bonheur au futur époux problème de CP
sachant que Carla Bruni reste avec un
homme en moyenne trois mois combien
d'hommes la belle italienne
pourrait-elle séduire en Milan
le prix du fayot cette semaine revient à
Didier Barbelivien avec la phrase
maintenant j'ai hâte d'écouter l'album
de Carla
le couple Sarkozy gagne contre Ryanair
la compagnie au frais 100000 billets
d'avion pour assister à leur mariage
rappelons que la compagnie ortefe
Airlines offre toujours 25000 billets à
nos amis sans papier
puis énorme déception pour David
Douillet qui pensait récupérer Carla
Bruni pour l'opération Pièces Jaunes et
bien Bernadette Chirac reste
il y a cru jusqu'au bout et puis cette
semaine ils sont bien sur une scène de
théâtre quand même on dirait Noël et
Hardy
économie Jérôme Kerviel montre enfin son
visage dans la presse Jérôme Kerviel Le
Roch Voisine du CAC 40 très beau très
gentil mais très nul
Dominique de Villepin mette en vente sa
collection consacrée à Napoléon oui les
hommes politiques de petite taille un
peu plus
comme ça
justice un employé de la Fondation
Bardot victime de maltraitance dans son
travail et alors c'est pas un animal
[Applaudissements]
société le premier greffé des deux mains
prend la plume écrire un livre avec des
mains qui ne sont pas les siennes une
mode lancée par Paul-Loup Sulitzer
[Applaudissements]
médecine des chercheurs ont expérimenté
sur des souris un vaccin contre le
cancer de la prostate en attendant le
toucher rectal reste le meilleur
dépistage chez l'homme chez l'homme et
j'ai une souris vous la tuer
d'après libération au centre Alzheimer
de Nice un patient à danser la
tectonique devant Nicolas Sarkozy
libération qui confond tectonique et
crise d'épilepsie
un espoir pour les malades d'Alzheimer
des impulsions électriques ont ravivé
chez un patient des souvenirs vieux de
30 ans la chaise électrique pourrait
soigner les cas les plus graves
[Applaudissements]
faits divers 54 ans après un glacier
rend un alpiniste à sa famille pour
congeler un bébé sans se faire arrêter
trop vite le glacier plus sûr que le
congélateur
un jeune homme qui est côté de la
musique avec un baladeur est mort écrasé
par un train qui n'avait pas entendu
arriver c'est l'avantage d'écouter du
Carla Bruni même un vélo tu l'entends
arriver
people le magazine Gala s'interroge
Lorie et Garou pourquoi ça dure entre
eux est-ce que quelqu'un a une idée
on s'en fout on s'en fout complètement
[Musique]
Jérôme rotten flashé à 232 km/h pour une
fois qu'un joueur du PSG fait une pointe
de vitesse c'est pas de chance
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour terminer une nouvelle qui nous
vient d'Allemagne un homme de 128 kg
condamnés à 50 prisons pour cette racise
sur sa femme il y a cassé 18 côtes oui
18 côtes dommage qu'à l'époque Carlier
ne se soit placé sur Fogiel
la semaine prochaine et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu